we are in an epidemic of bigger Exia and
male body dysmorphia men who look in the
mirror and see either pepper Ami's or
blobs rather than the medium-sized body
they've probably got I'm talking about
men descending into the equivalent of
anorexia bigger Exia neuroses about the
way we look looking in the mirror and
seeing what isn't you going after an
unrealistic goal that can ultimately
damage your help on my latest lads
holiday five of my friends refuse to
take their t-shirts off because they
were insecure about how they looked back
in my dad state was like man boobs out
ray bombing the poll steroid usage
massively prevalent just look at the
reality TV shows you can't get that body
just from doing a little bit of cardio
if you think I'm just being traumatic we
live in an era where male suicide is at
its highest male eating disorders are on
the rise this is a huge thing men are
looking in the mirror and their brains
are tripping out the end result Cardiff
high street is full of people that look
like they were made by the x-men these
are men injecting themselves this is
bigger Exia in action if I ask these men
they say back to me Russ you don't
understand its what a bird wants it's
what women what women want a big strong
doubt that lift them up repeat it
sometimes they drop into Morse code - OH
- testosterone - me metal
listen ladies I don't presume to
understand what women want but mostly
gentlemen the primary characteristic
that a woman is looking for is a man
that isn't an arse something that will
be made much much worse if you inject
yourself with steroids ironically bigger
Rexxar is not no it's come in several
phases it's started with Joe Weider and
Arnold Schwarzenegger when bodybuilding
exploded years ago my dad was heavily
involved my dad's neck was bigger than
my thigh nice true though I'm not
suggesting we shouldn't eat healthily be
a bit toned do some exercise make an
effort gents everyone likes that what
I'm suggesting is in our culture it can
be a bit of a turn-off to be a bit too /
I know it goes against everything we
know about Darwinian evolution but
British people are not attracted to
perfection it made me the opposite of my
old man he was 17 stone shaven-headed
doorman metal welder lifeguard semi
competitive bodybuilding oiled athlete
nut job and he had me for a son a skinny
pepper army stick with a glittery
question mark over the top I quite like
theater daddy but I do have a connection
to this I've never used steroids myself
really Poirot but my dad did my dad
massively used steroids he injected it
he lifted massively heavy weights and it
turned his aortic valve the one that
looks like a Mercedes sign into a
bicuspid double triangular flap that
could happen to you gentlemen so instead
of three flats opening every time you
breathe in and out
- over the years it sticks sticks sticks
sticks and if you make it to 16 you'll
be lucky that's what happened to my dad
heart attack boom gone very sad the only
upside I can now do stand-up about
Impaler mortgage pay healthy gents
[Music]